Make your luck. Yeah, you gotta
make your luck. And if you make it,
if you keep,
if you keep putting forth the maximal
effort that luck's gonna come,
you're gonna make your
luck happen. You know that,
you know that actually
when we, when we came,
when tasking a bruiser came home from
Iraq, there was, there was, you know,
people were like,
oh you guys got super lucky on that
deployment because we got a lot of action.
Right.
And there was two like immediate thoughts
behind that was number one like, hey,
you know, first of all we lost our bros.
Like there nothing lucky about that was
the first immediate thought in my head
was like, hey man,
like cause cause the bottom line is
seals want to go into combat bad.
And that's just a broad statement.
And so when we came home,
had been in a lot of combat and killed a
lot of bad guys and people were kind of
saying, Hey, you guys got
lucky. And, and again,
the first thought was, hey man, you
did. If this is luck, I don't want it.
The second thought was just like the
same thing. Like, oh, we got lucky.
We didn't like crush ourselves into
workup and try and be the most, you know,
prepared we could be and then get overseas
and form relationships with all the
conventional forces and do good work
for them and continue to w you know,
just get, go as hard as we
could the whole time. No,
that didn't have anything to do with.
It was just luck and it kind of fell
into our lap. But you know, of course,
just nod your head and say thanks man.
Appreciate it. Yeah, good times. Uh,
so luck is definitely a part of it.
A little part because where
was I lucky to be in Ramadi?
Cause I could have deployed a year later
and a year later Ramadi was pacified.
So is there a lock there?
There absolutely is. So,
I don't want to sound
arrogant, but luck is a part,
it's like foot locks. It's like heel
hooks. They're a part of the game.
They're not a game changer.
They're a part of the game.
They're not a game changer. We, we
had a group come in, and this is
back in the day, a group came in,
a guys that we're known for foot
locking and heel hook and what they did,
they thought we were Jujitsu
guys, normal [inaudible] guys,
but we weren't because
we were dean, right?
So we were foot locker and heel hugging
all the time and these guys came in and
immediately they were going for,
these are the kind of guys that
would go and I don't know if you,
I don't know if you remembered
this time period in Jujitsu,
it was like immediate. They're going for
a full lock, like just diving for it.
But they didn't know that we did
for the longest all the time.
And you weren't going to just grab a
full lock on Dean lister or me like that.
There's wasn't going to happen.
And it kind of Inventables also,
they didn't have the rest of Jujitsu.
You have the rest of the game.
So then it was not good for them because
they only had this one dimensional
game. And that's what taught me
that foot locks aren't important,
but they're not more important
than a choke or a guard pass.
They are definitely part of
game. You can't leave out,
but they're not a game
changer. And you see that now,
now that you see everyone broadly
getting good at at the whole leg,
locking foot, locking heel looking game.
Now you see it coming back around where
you have to have the rest of Jujitsu as
well. Even though even as much as
like a year ago, it was like, oh,
this guy got this crazy heel hook and
the guy tapped and you didn't know what
was happening. That very
rapidly changes into, okay,
the guy went for a heel hook, the
other guy got out. Now we've got to,
where are we back to? We're back
to the Jujitsu, so same thing.
Luck is a factor. It's
not the factor. Yeah.